il ya deux morceaux de bravoure si l'on
peut dire pour eux n'est pas réaliste
c'est évidemment la galerie des glaces
qui est quand même un petit challenge
est celui qui m'a donné le plus de fil à
retordre on dirait c'est la cour de
marbre
son livre est un carnet de voyage 128
aquarelles que michel du voisin a peint
au sein même du château de versailles
un travail méticuleux des jardins et des
pièces célèbres ou moins connus là
certaines salles où on m'a ouvert la
porte a ouvert les volets et après que
j'ai fait mes photos on à refermer les
volets et on est passé à la salle
suivante
ça s'est passé comme ça et même avec
notamment l'hémicycle du congrès ça
c'est par un député que j'ai pu avoir
accès à ces endroits là ancien
illustrateur de publicité michel du
voisin découvre l'aquarelle il ya 40 ans
une révélation
la légèreté dans le jeu on a pu
l'inconvénient des autres matières où il
ya des parties ne convenait pas je n'ai
pas retrouvé le parti de la crique à
l'huile s'est réellement l'on a séché
que c'est pas possible le vent à la
gouache un peu terne et où donc là d'un
seul coup j'ai découvert quelque chose
d'agréable à travailler mais celle du
voisin pain avec réalisme et élégance
ses toiles sont à découvrir sur
versailles jusqu'au 23 décembre